tu vois là sur ce t-shirt là il y a
marqué 1924 c'est la dernière fois que
les jeux ont eu lieu à Paris je veux
dire il y a des tas de mecs des tas de
filles qui sont passionnés comme moi
mais qui n'ont pas eu la chance de vivre
les Jeux Olympiques parce qu'ils sont
morts avant
oui les Jeux olympiques de 2020 n'ont
pas eu lieu en 2020 et tant mieux pour
moi puisque j'étais au fond du trou
et et que j'aurais été incapable de de
de gérer cette affaire-là
donc Madame la covid qui est vraiment ma
meilleure
copine parce que c'est elle qui a permis
au sport de s'arrêter quand j'étais au
fond du trou et et donc il m'a permis de
récupérer un petit peu et lorsque ces
Jeux de Tokyo ont lieu en 2021 je me
subeecteté un petit peu quand même mais
je n'ai pas les moyens d'aller à Tokyo
je ne suis plus à france télé et donc je
vais les faire à Paris il y a un copain
qui me m'installe un studio de télé dans
mon dans mon petit studio justement donc
la place pour rien faire d'autre que
faire de la télé et je vais donc depuis
Paris avec un fond vert sur la gare de
Tokyo et bien je vais commenter les Jeux
Olympique de Tokyo depuis Paris et et
c'est un moment magnifique parce que bon
c'est la première fois que je commente
les Jeux Olympiques sans avoir le droit
d'utiliser les images donc je gueule
comme ça tout seul face caméra j'ai
quelquefois des consultants en visio et
ça donne ça donne un moment de partage
très étonnant alors ils sont combien je
sais pas il y en avait peut-être 10 12
50 100 1000 dans le meilleur des cas qui
ont suivi radio Montel ce jour-là sur
Tokyo cette période là mais moi j'ai été
présent à ma manière en périphérie sur
ces Jeux Olympiques même si je n'étais
plus à France Télévision donc c'était
quelque chose de d'assez savoureux oui
alors ça je je je m'inscrit en faux
parce que c'est juste une une occasion
de me signifier mon âge en fait
c'est-à-dire que dans une histoire
d'amour il y a il y a l'usure du temps
tous ceux qui ont été amoureux me
comprendront il y a un moment où le
couple où la relation commence à
s'étioler et là elle s'étiole parce que
j'ai atteint un peu la limite d'âge quoi
j'ai 66 ans à l'époque donc voilà dans
la la retraite La retraite à 60 j'en
suis loin bon je sens qu'il y a une
usure je sens qu'il y a une volonté de
de la part de de mon amoureuse de de
mettre un terme à la relation comme
beaucoup d'amoureux transit je refuse de
m'en apercevoir et en fait cette
histoire du dopage qui n'en est pas une
et en fait l'occasion pour scellerler la
rupture en fait
mais il y a un moment où il faut faire
mal dans une rupture parce que celui qui
aime toujours bah il veut pas il veut
pas l'admettre donc j'en veux pas du
tout à mon amoureuse hein je veux dire
il y avait un moment fallait mettre un
point final ils ont mis un point final
après cette histoire de dopage mais
encore une fois là je vois aujourd'hui
il y a un influenceur alors un mec bien
plus influenceur que moi je crois
100000 followers c'est un mec qui a pas
apparemment est important je le
connaissais pas qui dit exactement la
même chose que moi c'està-dire le dopage
est consubstantiel du sport hyper
professionnel ça ne veut pas dire que
tous les athlètes se doppent ça veut
dire que la tentation de le faire existe
c'est le sentiment de tous ceux qui
aiment qui aiment leurs partenair et qui
sont largués quoi je veux dire le ciel
te tombe sur la tête tu te dis pourquoi
moi tu te dis qu'est-ce que j'ai fait de
mal tu te dis est-ce que je l'ai pas
assez bien aimé tu te dis pourvu qu'elle
Rev Vienne et puis elle revient pas donc
au début tu es au fond du trou au début
tu tu te dis mais c'est pas possible ce
qui m'arrive et cetera et puis après tu
réfléchis après tu réfléchis ma relation
avec elle elle a duré plus de 30 piges
donc voilà et tu te dis ben il va
falloir reconstruire quelque chose et à
ce moment-là tu as une copine qui arrive
c'est mademoiselle covid et elle te dit
attends mec reprends-toi reprends-toi je
vais arrêter le sport pendant un an et
puis tu vas pouvoir te reconstruire
c'est ce que je fais avec la création de
radio Montel qui vient sur cette période
post-covid où je m'intéresse aux gens
qui pratiquent le sport mais aux
amateurs à monsieur madame tout le monde
qui font des efforts longs et à qui on
tend jamais le micro de cette idée-là
est né donc ce média qui s'appelle radio
Montel et qui aujourd'hui flirte avec
les 300000 abonnés donc il y avait
vraiment une voix à prendre pour se
reconstruire et c'est ce qui s'est passé
après une période c'est vrai douloureuse
moi je les gens qui sont bienveillants
les gens qui ont la reconnaissance c'est
des gens qui me font pleurer donc euh
Vincent et lad euh m'ont fait pleurer
d'autres aussi d'ailleurs parce que ce
qu'ils ont fait c'était gratuit personne
leur a demandé de le faire et surtout
pas moi idem pour celui qui a lancé la
pétition que je ne connais pas mais que
je remercie euh ce sont des gens qui ont
été bienveillants aujourd'hui le
problème pour moi et notamment sur les
réseaux c'est le manque de bienveillance
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on ne
connaît pas quelqu'un et on l'ASS
sans autre forme de procès donc voilà je
veux dire c'est facile de taper sur la
tête des gens quand on les connaît pas
mais c'est difficile de leur rendre
hommage quand on les connaît et qu'on
sait qu'on peut s'attirer des inimitiés
donc ce que fait Vincent de l'erme ce
qu'a fait spontanément Vincent deerne
laadjid dououré et quelques autres ce
sont des des des actes gratuits qui
m'ont donné une énergie folle pour
pouvoir continuer à mon chemin quoi pour
les gios de de Paris 2 24 je suis je
suis très serein aujourd'hui euh j'ai
j'ai demandé en temps et en heure une
une accréditation pour Radio Montel qui
m'a été refusé sans que je connaisse la
raison de de ce refus après je me dis
peut-être qu'un média qui est accrédité
lui va me proposer quelque chose un
strapontin sans prendre la place de
quelqu'un juste pour que je puisse
commenter quelque chose je ne sais pas
ça reste un gros point d'interrogation
mais je me dis dans tous les cas
c'est-à-dire même si j'ai rien du tout
je commenterai les Jeux Olympique de
Paris 2024 je les commenterai en dehors
de la zone olympique puisque j'aurais
pas le droit de rentrer dans la zone
olympique mais je les commentterai dans
des endroits insolites où les gens n'ont
pas eu soit la chance d'avoir une place
parce que ça coûtait trop cher soit ne
peuvent pas être chez eux pour regarder
devant la télévision il y aura des tas
d'endroits comme ça en France et moi je
serai là pour com er avec eux les jeux
pour partager cette grande fête parce
que c'est pas parce qu'on me refuse une
accréditation que je vais me priver de
cet événement tu vois là sur ce t-shirt
là il y a marqué 1924 c'est la dernière
fois que les jeux ont eu lieu à Paris je
veux dire il y a des tas de mecs des tas
de mecs des tas de filles qui sont
passionnés comme moi mais qui n'ont pas
eu la chance de vivre les Jeux
Olympiques parce qu'ils sont morts avant
moi je suis encore vivant je veux y
participer si on me donne pas ce carton
ce sésame pas grave il y a pas de souci
je les commenterai de l'ex inérieur